hi so my name is Sylvia Callie know you
and and technically for the cloud
dataflow called a tough law for Python
and to me is also Eric Anderson with the
program manager for the team before I
start I'm just curious never show of
hands how many people heard of cloud
dataflow all right I was asking how many
people have heard of cloud dataflow okay
so in the next 30 minutes we're just
gonna build from scratch
typical ETL pipeline processing pipeline
that will take some text files in JSON
format and I'll put some aggregated data
to a bigquery table just like a typical
thing that you do with this kind of
systems so before I start I have two
slides that are written by some
colleagues of mine I'm gonna keep it
short but just to kind of give you a
background of what is cloud dataflow and
how we arrived there so a long time ago
in 2004 he was MapReduce there was a
seminal paper from Google that started
two divergent efforts so inside Google
for many years they continued to
innovate but outside all you have seen
it's just a bunch of PDFs for various
systems flume Java mill-wheel
Dremel and a bunch of other things
whereas outside the open-source
community continued to innovate for all
these years and they created their own
ecosystem of tools there was a little
bit of cross-reference through the
papers published in both ways but other
than that Google
actually had a public system that people
can play with in 2014 they announced we
announced Google Cloud dataflow which is
based it's a combination of something
called flume Java it's an internal
system for describing batch computations
by describing processing graph of custom
transforms in it this is combined also
with a system called millville which is
used for streaming processing so that's
actually one of the major advancements
with cloud dataflow it's this
combination of a unified API both for
batch and stream processing and quite
recently in January 2016 the cloud
dataflow team together with some
industry partners they contributed the
model to the Apache Software Foundation
in a project incubating project that's
called Apache beam so I'm saying all
this stuff because you probably you'll
hear about Apache bean cloud dataflow so
this is kind of the history of it so at
this point we like to call it the Apache
beam all
processing model for question data both
pageant streaming and clouded a
florist's really just a service offer
for Google to to run such a pipeline in
our own cloud but the model is called
Apache beam now
so as I said before I'm not gonna delve
more on this Oh one thing I forgot to
mention here so cloud dataflow shipped
with a Java SDK API so basically
these processing graphs
so what I'm gonna talk now is a much
more recent project where we offer the
same mock computation model in Python so
that's something new that we just week
ago we launched our alpha version so as
I said you can with the Java one you can
do both batch and streaming so you can
have bounded sources of data or you can
have unbounded we basically can process
forever incoming data in Python right
now we support down avenge so we're
still working on streaming so it's gonna
come on but right now we support only
batch and this is what I'm gonna show
you today
so I just want to if I want you to
remember four concepts that they're
gonna show up in the coding I'm gonna
call them out then but the for our
pipeline so this is the thing where you
put your processing graph this is your
object where you put your you construct
your processing graph you associate with
it a runner so runner can be something
that will run your the graph that you
just described locally on your local
machine or it could be something that
will run in a cluster in a cloud for
Java for instance they're actually
runners there's a flink run or in a
spark Runner which are this equivalent
systems from the open source community
for describing this kind of computations
were basically the same graph you so use
the Apache beam model to describe your
computation and then with a flink Runner
that computation will be submitted to a
Flint cluster and run there in Python we
don't support that so right now we
support only a direct run art which runs
locally and Google Google Cloud Runner
which will run the computation in a
Google cluster so pipelining a runner
the other two concepts are pea
collection and P transform so think of
pea collection as
very very large list this is what flows
between through the edges of processing
graph so if you want conceptually it's a
little bit more complicated but
conceptually think of a directed acyclic
graph where the nodes are Pietra are
transforms that do various computations
on that incoming data and output some
other data and through the edges flow
these big collections so you will see
that basically the graph is about
chaining these P transforms and doing
something with the P collections and in
terms of P transforms really there are
four important types so it's first the
in nodes and out nodes or read transform
and a write transform that allow it to
insert or output data from the
processing graph and then you have a
parallel do which is something custom
that you do for each incoming element of
a P collection and group by key which is
something that will expect those input P
collection that contains key value pairs
and it will group group the values by
keys it's a pretty so if you think of it
parallel do is the map part of MapReduce
and group by key is the sort of the
reduced part of MapReduce but the thing
with all the system modern systems so
dataflow but also flink and spark is
that it's not just one MapReduce you
have a whole bunch of MapReduce releases
chained together in this graph so so one
more thing before we start coding so the
process the the project is on github you
can check it out there is a form here
that will allow you to sign up for our
alpha program if you want you don't need
the to sign up if you just want to play
with it locally but if you want to run
against the Google cluster you need to
sign up and right now it's kind of
invite-only so we need to whitelist
people before they run against
cluster the other thing to mention is
that we're also moving to a patchy beam
so right now we're in a separate little
repository but eventually we're going to
be also part of the beam incubating
project and as I said we don't have
streaming yet and the other thing is
that the Java version has a plethora of
sources and syncs so you can reach roll
through from all sorts of things in
Python right now we can read and write
only to Google Cloud storage files or
local files and bigquery tables by the
way I'm just curious how many people
know what bigquery is
ok so many more people so beaker is the
word warehousing solution from Google
it's a pretty awesome no nobs
warehousing solution ok
so what we're gonna start doing stuff
now so the first thing I recommend is
whenever you play with something you use
the virtual environment so for your
sanity because while you're going to
install to all sorts of packages and you
don't want to install them in a global
environment
all right so as I said to our friends
so this is the github repository I'm
just gonna install the latest release
zero to one
there is one more step actually that I'm
a little bit lying here there is one
more step that you need to do that's
already installed on this you need to
install a bunch of cool google cloud
tools but it's all described in the
readme that's in github if you want to
play with it alright so we have clean
slate here now it's clean so the first
thing when so we're going to basically
describe a computation we're going to
have some toy files locally and then
we're gonna have somewhat bigger files
in towards the end where we're gonna run
against we're gonna run in the Google
cluster so the first thing you do is you
just import the package so this is kind
of standard way of doing it it would be
nice if this is just and would be stable
alright so remember the concept so the
first thing is we create a pipeline
object because that's what we're going
to put all our computation graph
and for now we're gonna use the pipeline
direct pipeline runner which is
basically we're gonna run this locally
later we're gonna use another one so the
first thing we're gonna read some data
so I'm just gonna write it and then I'm
gonna talk about it so basically we are
applying a free transform
that will read from text file source and
in this case is just one file that I
have it I have it here locally so is
this data in just as this a bunch of
JSON records line by line all right so
what I said here is that okay apply this
retransform
and create this PC variable this is a P
collection the P collection is gonna
contain each element is gonna be one
line from the file so the line it could
be the file could be as very big it
could be actually a collection of files
it doesn't matter
conceptually what you get at the output
is a big collection with all these lines
together and now we're gonna do
something very simple we're gonna write
up a collection out
right so what I'm doing here this three
lines up I build a processing graph very
simple one in fact is probably the most
ridiculously complicated file copy that
you can ever imagine but you know he's
gonna get more interesting so the only
thing that you it's missing you need to
actually initiate the runner so you need
to run the pipeline so that's all you
have to do all right so now I got this
stuff in the output file fine so now
let's try to do a projection here so I
have this Jason records with a bunch of
fields I want to filter to get only the
product ID on price because what I want
in the end I want an aggregation per
product ID how much stuff eyes I have
been I sold right so the first thing I
want to to filter on the product IDM
price so first of all there's no need to
split split it like I live by line oh by
the way one thing I should mention we
call this the pipe operator in general
we try to make this API very pythonic so
we have just a lot about it the pipe
operator was something that we were very
proud of but when we present it to
people it's split 50-50 between
people considering its pythonic and
other people be nonplussed by it so but
for now we stuck with it I think it's a
good metaphor it reminds you of the pipe
operator in when you do a batch commands
so anyway what I want to say is that you
don't have to create all these temporary
variables you can just write the whole
thing in one pop like this
so now I want to for each element I want
to filter only the the fields that I
want so basically I'm going to apply a
parallel do so in Python data flow there
are three types of parallel dues that
they're basically all do the same thing
but there are small variations so a map
is one that maps an incoming element one
to one to an output element so it's one
to one there is a flat map that will map
one element to zero or more elements and
there is a pardhu which takes a
generalized form you need to define a
subclass of a do a fan class and it
takes a bunch of extra options but with
map and flatmap you just specify lambda
functions or normal Python functions so
in this case let's say I have a purse
record function that I need to define so
let's see purse record so this takes one
element if you look at the pipeline
actually what what's going to get it is
going to be called for each line of the
input file right so let's say I want to
get a record out of it and then I want
to return the called
product ID and the price
so let's see what we got here
that's interesting
okay so this is the I was missing the
nests so load actually reads from I
don't know load s reads from a string
load which problem file or something
yeah so this is gonna okay so now I I
got the the data filtered alright so the
next thing that I want to do is I want
to group this by so sorry I'm kind of
glossing over I don't know exactly the
level of Python knowledge here but
basically what I'm returning here is a
to topple in this line 6 this is how you
represent key value pairs in Python data
flow so whenever you want a key value
pair you return a to topple and key
value pairs are very very common because
whenever you want to do grouping that's
what you need you need key value pairs
so in this case we're gonna use one of
the grouping transforms not group by key
something called combine perky
so imagine combined party will do
something like this so as an as an input
you get these key value pairs right and
lots and lots of them and this combined
per key is gonna group all the values
for each key so each key is gonna have
basically a list of values and then it's
gonna apply my it's going to apply a
combining function to all the values
associated with the key so basically
what you get you get key some of the
values associated with a key something
like that which is exactly what I want
because I want to add up all the sales
for a particular product ID
all right so now I got my final result I
want to show you something else that's
interesting before we start doing the
bigquery part so as you noticed at this
point we're out put putting everything
into a local file I want to show you how
you can use here a flat map so the
difference between map and flatmap is
that map is one-to-one and flat map
returned is a mapping from one to an
iterable of values zero or more so if I
say flat map here now this becomes
incorrect the function the way it's
written and the reason it's incorrect is
what this returns returns the to topple
well it so happens that the to topple is
an iterable which means that this
infrastructure that the whole framework
is going to consider that the two values
associated with an input are going to be
product ID then price which is not what
you want you want the key value or both
of them grouped together and so this is
the kind of stuff that Python is very
hard compared to Java so in Java there's
this strong type system so you will not
be able to make this kind of style
mistakes so in Python because we don't
want this to happen so the reason I mean
obviously people did the program in
Python and they get used they kind of
develop defense mechanism to deal with
this kind of stuff but in this case it
could be even costly I mean it could be
that for instance you don't run it
locally or you send it to the cloud we
are going to pay $1,000 to discover that
you miss the type because in a cloud
usually pay money for your resources so
because of that we we have type checking
in the system so for instance if I do
this which is a very common mistake it
turns out you are gonna get an error
and so there's a lot of gobbledygook
here but basically here it says that
down that hey I'm expecting a key value
pair there is more to this we have
system of type hinting you can actually
eight the framework you can be more
specific about so you can have your own
optional type system in there just to
aid with this kind of situations in
Python by in this case the only the way
to fix it is to change return to yield
so this will turn parse record into a
generator and then basically can be used
as an iterator so now suddenly
everything is going to become correct
again
so one more thing before we go to
bigquery I'm gonna show you the it's
pretty boilerplate code but you know if
you ever play with this you are going to
hit this lets take command line
parameters in instead of this hard coded
data in and data out so the way you do
that kind of the idiomatic way is to use
the our power standard module
so let's say I want an input argument
and an output one
a few more boilerplate code
by the way this part with argument
parsing was a early pain point with
customer play customers playing with
this stuff it was kind of difficult to
you know introduce your arguments into
the pipeline
alright so we used
mr. modules
okay so what we achieved is that now we
can write these beautiful command line
parameters
all right
so the reason we did that we're gonna
need when we're not gonna submit to the
cluster work and I need these input
parameters and since he was such a
painful for previous customers now if
you use it you saw it once at least how
to write this boilerplate argument
parsing thing so be query source now so
instead of writing to a sink now we're
gonna write to a big worried sink
instead of a texting
a bigquery sync takes several parameters
but at a minimum you will take a table
and if the table does not exist is gonna
require a schema also so in this case
the schema were playing with this
Product ID price so let's say we want a
schema that has a field product ID
that's type integer and the value field
that type float so that's one thing one
modification the other thing that needs
to be modified is that big query sink
expects so the pea collection that's the
input of the beaker is thing is supposed
to be each element is the dictionary
describing a row so this is not what we
get out of combined per key out of
combined Purkey we get key value pairs
so we're going to need to write a little
transform function transfer a transform
operation
so we're going to use our friend map for
that and this time we're gonna define on
the spot the function using a lambda
function so what we get on the ins the
input we're going to get a product ID
and a value or a price and what we want
to return is dictionaries
something like that
so now the adapting between combine
perky and the right thing is done one
other thing so we're gonna run this in
the cloud now you can also run it
locally we support that why I'm gonna
skip that step we're now running in the
cloud one thing that it's useful when
you run it in the cloud we should
probably make it easier basically you
need to enable logging at a certain
level otherwise you will not see a bunch
of debug output that happens when you
run from the command line so especially
if you are playing with your pipeline
and you want to see what's going on you
will need this stuff
all right
so now this is ready this is the final
thing this is how you run you so when
you run it in the cluster you are going
to have to add more parameters it's not
going to be as easy as Python Karen that
PI but not by much so and in particular
there learn that many knobs so first you
need to specify project which is the
Google cloud project is something that
you know you go to Google and you define
your own project if you use bigquery you
need to put also your credit card other
projects are more starter where you can
just go for free it's not I mean
actually it I want to talk about prices
but it's you need to specify a job name
whatever you want you need to call it
some something I'm changing the runner
so this is one thing where the that
argument parsing thing helped because
now we are using instead of using the
direct pipeline runner we use the
blocking dataflow pipeline which is the
the one that is gonna submit the job to
the Google cluster and I'm actually I'm
gonna tell you more while this is
running in the after I launched it about
what's happening but basically the only
knob right now it's the number of
workers there is a product that's not
enabled for Python in part of the Google
Cloud dataflow where you don't need even
the NAM workers we out of scale based on
your throughput and things like that
but right now you for Python need to
specify the number of workers so this is
gonna run with 10 VM instances in the
cloud crunching data and then the other
things are basically the input now is go
cloud storage file which is exactly the
same file that we play with locally
output is a big query table and then you
specify some Google Cloud storage
staging and temporary locations where
they're all sort of pipeline artifacts
are going
placed like temporary files and things
that need to be staged so
so this is gonna start running in so
actually what happens now well while
this is running Sony is gonna start
outputting all sort of debug messages
about things so it connected to the
service it starts doing things so what
happens here so we have a description of
the processing graph then we we did we
issue the p dot run which invokes this
dataflow runner this time but this
runner does is not gonna run anything
locally what is gonna do is gonna create
a JSON description of the entire
computation and describing the whole
graph including things like oh there are
some custom functions in there what do I
do them I need to serialize them somehow
put them somewhere so that they can pick
picked up in the workers because I'm
gonna run all this custom code in VM
instances in the cluster
nothing is run locally so all this stuff
is done by the dataflow Runner so it
submits to the service this JSON
description of the computation plus a
bunch of artifacts with serialized
functions that means - they need to be
run in the cloud and then it lets the
Google Cloud dataflow service that
receive this to orchestrate the whole
execution of the graph so locally if you
look because it's all in github if you
look at what runs locally is basically
the local Runner is gonna do a
topological traversal of the graph and
execute all the nodes but in the cloud
there is a full service that
orchestrates these things and in
particular it does very clever
optimizations so for example like the
trivial one would be to avoid putting
stuff to disk until it's absolutely
necessary so for example if you have
let's say three parallel dues in a row
so a naive way to do it do it would be
ok so I'm gonna have to run first part
do get through all the pea collections
and I'm gonna put them to disk in and to
an inter intermediary file or so bunch
of files and then I'm gonna start the
second part do and take three from the
father
so this doesn't happen actually all the
part dues that are part us that are in a
chained are gonna be fused together and
executed together so there are a bunch
of optimizations like that that make it
much more performant because you know if
you avoid this guy or that will make it
more performant so now we can look at
Google Cloud console to look at our
project
so for the ones that are running in the
Google in Google cloud you can you have
a monitoring device so this is the the
one that's running right now it's almost
done so it marked the last step the
right succeeded so it's gonna take a
little bit more time to actually finish
completely because the orchestrator
that's the Google service also needs to
start vm stop vm so now at this point
probably it's stopping closing down all
the VMS that did the computation so you
have this graph one thing that I want to
show you because I'm pretty sure if you
play with this we are gonna have to
debug it so we have worker logs so for
example each each worker blocks a bunch
of things about what's being processing
what's going on there there is a bunch
of the worker startup log these are the
two most where you're gonna spend your
time if you play this a worker startup
is actually the one that starts the VMS
executing the Python code so there is a
bunch of packaging stalls in there that
can fail so if you have to debug that
you're gonna have to look here so let's
see so this is done at this point is
finished and pretty much that's it
actually
yeah oh sorry no no I want to show you
that actually it worked so so I'm gonna
look at there's a big query cloud
console and if you remember still vc
demo is the is the table that i was
creating and it actually created the
same the same values
at the product IDs and the values so
here you go proof that it actually works
so yeah that's that's a final thing